je vous posais des questions sur leur
corps malade venir' vraie ou fausse
anecdotes parce que ce gars a une vie de
ouf quand même vrai ou faux quand corps
malade a déjà mangé une pizza à larache
posé par terre dans une loge avec céline
dion
vrai ou faux oui c'est vrai on est là
céline dion ils sont assez proches
tournoi ouais rené la taupe et céline
dounia
c'est vrai que l'aspect de margherita
nom me céline dion c'est une règle pas
tomber à zéro c'est complètement fou non
mais c'est quoi cette histoire a connu
les pizzas autour des oreilles j'ai
écrit elle m'a proposé d'écrire une
chanson pour elle pour son album depuis
j'en ai écrit deux fois la mairie voilà
la première
la mère et l'enfant ces lignes
[Musique]
alors pour vous chez vous ça se corse
comme ça c'est comme ça c'est un
balayage voilà est en fait derrière cet
immense diva classe et tout et voilà on
l'a un peu quand même elle et
supernatural est super elle même on a
fait une promo ensemble on s'est
retrouvé dans la loge avait la bella
d'allier une pizza qui est arrivé on a
partagé un bout de pizza n'est pas le
cominois le droit de partir et partager
des aliments c'est bon voilà c'est
peut-être déposerait c'est dingue à la
différence entre nous et grand corps
malade grand corps malade 1 lui il
partage depuis 10 avec céline dion
gilles verdez il s'en prend une volée
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous avez déjà partagé comme ça un
moment avec une grande star auto data
bernard montiel bien sur lui oui ah oui
vidéo gag farouk votre chien alors oui
oui oui plusieurs fois c'est arrivé avec
kick et alain delon métier oui bien sûr
de long - delon belmondo
ouais le plein de gens oui bien sûr mais
c'était quoi passer pendant leur eux
c'est qu'ils faisaient avec vous qui se
faisait avec moi c'était avant ou après
une interview et kiki diabel des anges
les mecs le même de long mais pas le
même jacques bernard si on avance on
avance on avance
moi j'ai fais pipi à côté d'usain bolt
non à oui et quand il est avec moi non
c'était une faisait une promotion il
faisait des structures électrique en
panne et il était là mais jamais vu
avant mais la ville est restée plusieurs
jours à paris et jamais venu à 20 pour
une soirée soirée pour la promotion de
la truck côté du chêne paul elkaïm et
quand il m'a de surveillance son pipi va
plus vite tous
gaïdar est tombé pile et rapide tu vaux
pas fou fan de michael jordan grand
corps malade a déjà jouer les groupies
en allant jusqu'à l'embrasser dans un
resto michael jordan
alors vrai ou faux ça c'est possible
mais ce n'est pas impossible non titre
c'est vrai c'était en 2006 et là et moi
j'ai un angle est absolument impeccable
vous avez pas le vérifier
et j'avais préparé ma petite phrase je
lui ai dit you know michael holland
everybody loves you ain't nobody love
you like a et la venue à l'américaine
c'est lui qui m'a pris dans ses bras il
me gay comme ça fait de sa poésie ont
rencontré une énorme star vous êtes allé
d'avoir ou desdites y aller oui j'ai
fait pipi avec ma conjointe
[Applaudissements]
spilak
le producteur de grand corps malade lui
a fait une blague donc jean rachid en
faisant venir que des personnes voilà
qui l'insulté pendant un concert
résultat il s'est fait insulter traité
de connard toute la soirée élevé il faut
battre amis donc il va être la guerre
quand même c'est pas tout à fait ça
c'est faux mais presque ça qu'est ce qui
vous a fait du rachis ça c'est faux donc
j'ai pas se passer soit il ya bouquet
les deux premiers rangs ah oui entre
personnes fictives
ici les deux premiers rangs vide en fait
je savais que rachid et qui galèrent y
fait des blagues ces voix là je sais que
chercher à faire donc là on était en
voiture et galérer il a appelé les
responsables d'un festival en disant à
quoi comme spectacle ce soir lundi à
grand corps malade et 10 et s'est fait
passer pour le fils du producteur de
jeux pas quoi il a dit je veux les deux
premiers rangs vide parce que je vais
amener tous mes invités jeudi c'est
impossible c'est complet il a dit si
l'enjeu sinon je n'y aura pas de
subvention pour votre festival année
prochaine machin donc qu'est bon on a
oublié l'histoire de la blague ou à
l'aller on a fini une autre journée et
au moment du concert je monte sur scène
j'avais oublié sa blague mais là il y
avait les deux premières enquêtes
[Applaudissements]
jaugeant rachid et riba 6 abbas et lui
un soft vous surnommé mon petit chaton
bleus bien à
il paraît que vous collectionnez les
figurines des schtroumpfs quand j'avais
7 ans j'ai arrêté il est toujours
dangereux par contre mes supers la
chemise mais je trouve moi je suis resté
bleus tout cas il fait un très bon
retour
à 12 ans fabien failli se battre pour
obtenir un autographe de bernard minet
vrai ou faux non non non non non mais il
rêvait d'avoir un autographe d'un autre
artiste c'est elle qui m'a dit road ou à
wayne je les lui à 12 ans à peu près
ouais c'était un concert j'ai réussi à
vaincre husté derrière parce que c'était
en plein air j'étais passé sous une
palissade derrière la scène et voilà
j'avais eu mon premier autographe à peu
près à devant un rêve un chrono et au
dos de renouer ben voila et bravo à
grand corps malade